- I got something on my mind, right here,
I just put out a video, "How to Start",
and I'm reading all the comments,
and it dawned on me.
I need to make a two minutes version
of the raw version of what I'm
actually saying which is quite simple.
I'm making this video for one reason,
so that you can link to it when
people shit on you and doubt you.
I am tired of people not starting
and living their life on one very
simple thing which is they're worried
about what other people think,
whether that's their mom, their friends,
and worst of all: fucking comments
in social media.
I mean this is some sixth
grade lunchroom shit.
Are you really, really, really
not gonna live your life based
on somebody's anonymous fucking
icon feedback that "you suck"?
They fucking suck.
They're free fucking trash,
that's why I fucking found a dumpster.
Let them come to me.
Let me make this video so that
you can point to me so I can say
to them very simply,
"Are you serious, my man?
Are you serious?
Like you literally have time to
leave negative reviews
on other people's shit?
Is your shit so fucked up?
Is it so sad that you take your
time to allocate poison and negativity
on other people's stuff?
Get out of the way and let people
do their thing."
Now, back to you guys,
who are watching this.
It's enough.
You've lived your whole life this way.
It doesn't matter what they think.
When you're fucking ninety-two
and you're sitting there,
you're not gonna give a shit about
what "Punkman96" had to say.
Or even what your aunt had to say,
who's miserable 'cause she never got hers,
so she's trying to keep you down.
So very simply, please
take the passion that is
pouring out of my fucking face
right now and run with
it and go do something.
If you need a little burst, here it is.
Go do something because the only
thing that's holding you back
is you're worried about what other
people have to say.
You give up on that shit and you're
clean and you can go.
And all of a sudden,
it's not how much money you have
or how much time you have.
You just see that you can do it.
Money and time ain't shit of holding
you back compared to your worry
about other people's opinions.
Leave that shit in high school.
It's time to go.
(exhales, laughter)